et pour parler du discours du président
libanais michel aoun qui s'étaient
exprimés donc en début de soirée nous
sommes avec claude blanchemaison expert
en relations internationales
le blanchemaison bonsoir merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
nous venons d'entendre le discours de
michel aoun qu'est-ce que vous pouvez en
retenir sa discours relativement bref
mais très dense
d'abord dans une première partie il a
décrit la lah quadruples crise dont le
liban faisait l'objet une crise
économique et financière très sérieuse
qui dure depuis près de dix ans et
d'ailleurs il n'a pas dit que les
responsables libanais à n'avait pas
n'avaient pas su traiter cette crise
deuxièmement la crise des réfugiés
il en a parlé en effet le liban et il
demande à ce que les réfugiés syriens
puissent repartir en syrie et que un
jour les réfugiés palestiniens puissent
aussi repartir chez eux
et puis troisièmement la crise du coup
vite comme tout le monde
et quatrièmement l'explosion
catastrophique du port de beyrouth avec
la destruction de ce port vital pour le
pays d'ailleurs pour une partie du
proche orient et d'une partie de la
ville de beyrouth aussi il a remercié
les pays qui s'étaient qui avaient
détecté déclarait des aides d'urgence en
faveur du liban dont la france est aussi
remercié le pape en passant et puis
finalement il a souligné que les pays
qui avaient annoncé des aides
importantes donc les bailleurs de fonds
devait maintenant s'exécuter
c'est-à-dire verser ces fonds aux
autorités libanaises qui naturellement
les utiliserai dans le cadre défini par
les instances de l'onu commençait
certaines de ces certains certains de
ces de certaines de ces aides sont
conditionnées par des réformes au liban
le président lahoud n'a pas tout parlé à
aucun moment
peut-être que ça n'était pas d'ailleurs
le lieu pour en parler
alors il a aussi évoqué l'intégrité
territoriale du liban avec le respect
d'un certain nombre de résolutions des
nations unies en disant qu'israël
devrait notamment respecter cette
souveraineté y compris sur les zones
maritimes qui sont sous la juridiction
du liban d'après le droit international
d'après le droit de la mer dont il s'est
invité par là dans le grand marchandage
qui est commence en méditerranée
orientale sur les zones qui contiennent
des ressources pétrolières ou gazières
et donc le président libanais
naturellement à a fait l'apologie du
multi râle du multilatéralisme et de
l'onu et son rôle au liban
alors lundi le président avait prévenu
que le pays se dirigerait vers l'enfer
sans gouvernement alors où est ce qu'on
en est aujourd'hui
oui alors à un nouveau premier ministre
a été a été nommé il a été nommé avec
les précautions habituelles au liban
puisque comme vous le savez le
traditionnellement et en fonction
d'accords politiques dont était passée
il ya il ya longtemps
le président est chrétien le premier
ministre est sunnite et le président du
parlement et cite à présent super parle
du parlement est d'ailleurs en place
depuis très longtemps depuis le début de
ces accords pris parti et pour la
nomination du nouveau premier ministre
on a nommé un technocrate un ancien
ambassadeur à berlin qui a été dans les
cabinets de premier ministre libanais et
ce premier ministre évidemment et un
sunnite et à rechercher la bénédiction
de tous les premiers ministres ils ont
précédés
mais il n'arrive pas aujourd'hui a formé
son gouvernement parce que le
le hezbollah et les chiites et par
conséquent le parti du président du
parlement considère que les chrétiens
ont la part trop belle
c'est aussi un chrétien qui est à la
tête de la delà de la banque centrale
est un autre qui est à la tête de des
armées libanaises et par conséquent les
chiites veulent absolument le ministère
des finances est pas par hasard puisque
évidemment le ministère des finances
c'est la troisième signature il ya celle
du président celle du premier ministre
et celle du ministre des finances pour
toutes les mesures important le premier
ministre désigné
s'ils refusent d'ailleurs probablement
aidé en cela par monsieur hariri qui
voudrait casser ce partage des zones
d'influencé surtout des ministères
régaliens et encore plus de ceux qui
peuvent rapporter
par conséquent on en est là la situation
est bloquée il faut faire preuve
d'imagination
je pense que les libanais sont capables
de faire preuve d'imagination
il est vrai que la date limite que leur
avait fixé monsieur macro est d'ores et
déjà dépassé
mais il faudra attendre un petit peu
sans doute pour que ce gouvernement soit
formé mais il sera probablement informé
avec deux jeunes technocrates compétents
mais qui répondront aux affiliations
habituel aux trois catégories qui sont
les catégories religieuse parce que
c'est le liban on ne peut pas
transformer le liban
du jour au lendemain merci beaucoup
claude blanche maison pour votre analyse
je rappelle que vous êtes expert en
relations internationales